It's hard to believe,
but Thursday marks three years since the
final episode of breaking bad air on TV
while it was on breaking bad grip,
the culture of more tightly than almost
any other show and its legacy is still
intact today,
I think because the arc of episodes that
concluded the story brought a satisfying
and brutal reckoning on what came
before.
I think the best episode of the series
can be found in that arch and today I
want to talk about that episode as
humanity is the poem it references and
how the ideas in both help us understand
the show as a whole.
In a lot of ways.
This episode though,
third from the last book ends the entire
series right or more wily Beckett makes
this explicit by staging the pre opening
credits scene as a flashback to the
first episode when Walter White and
Jesse Pinkman are making their very
first batch of crystal Meth,
the reaction has begun.
The narrative of the show is its own
kind of chemical reaction brought about
by choices like walters choice to make
crystal meth to raise money for his
cancer treatment.
Like the first lie,
he's rehearsing to tell his wife about
this,
that lead to the horrifying consequences
we're about to witness director Ryan
Johnson makes these things explicit in
another way.
We're more wildly.
Beckett,
has plot and dialogue.
Johnson has visuals,
visuals like the slow fading of past
elements that show the passage of time
and the disappearance of the people and
the things that once were.
What we see in this episode is
effectively the bloody end of
Heisenberg's rain.
But what's interesting is how not bloody
it is while he beckett in Johnson placed
the focus instead on reactions,
reaction shots,
and so we get an episode of Gazans.
Quizzical gates is angry,
gazes blankies is penetrating gazes.
What's important isn't that wall gets
away with holly,
for example,
but that skylar sees it.
The death of Hank is showed for all of
two seconds before Ryan Johnson quickly
cuts away.
Compare this to the 44 seconds.
He lingers on Walt Skyler's,
Flynn's emory's reaction to that news.
So in this episode we see Walter White
through the eyes of everyone else,
including virtually all of the key
players in the show.
And as is often the case,
these people see more about walt,
then he can about himself,
the smartest guy I ever met.
He made up his mind 10 minutes ago.
All these reactions,
these gates makes waltz,
own tragedy even more stark.
It's his inability to see himself
through the eyes of those around him.
Other people's gazes are like a mirror
that we use to see ourselves as Johnson
highlights twice in this episode.
Waltz not ready to look into mirrors yet
when he arrives home later in the
episode,
he uses all his regular to me,
negotiated everything is going to be
fine.
Both of you to trust me.
You have to go right now.
But his words fall flat on skylar and
they sound absurd to us.
While he beckett uses these words
brilliantly.
I think as an extension of Walt's
blindness,
I mean this is the climactic scene of
the episode and the climactic moment in
the scene is not the fight between
Walton skylar,
but our reaction bracketed by two
versions of the same line,
but first time walt screams it.
But when he finally glimpses himself
through the eyes of his family,
those same words deflate entirely.
This is where we can find some insight
in the episode title Ozymandias,
which references a sonnet by Percy
shelley from 18,
18.
In fact,
it's the poem that Bryan Cranston reads
in a promotional video for the season
showing that Vince Gilligan and the
writers wanted to highlight this
connection.
The poem tells the story of Shelly's
meeting with a traveler who describes in
detail a ruined sculpture of Ozymandias,
the Greek name for Ramses,
the second,
the most powerful Pharaoh of the
Egyptian empire,
and the empty landscape where his great
empire used to stand.
Some of the parallels here are obvious
like this shot where Walter white falls
rigidly to the ground like a statue
crumbling like walters frown and
wrinkled lip,
like the lone level sands stretch far
away,
Ryan Johnson even stages some visual
flourishes like having the broken glass
of the car window look a lot like
Walton,
Jesse's blue meth,
visualizing their empire fading into the
desert like the poem breaking bad is a
comment on the transients of power and
the arrogance of those who acquire it,
but the poem is also about seeing
through the eyes of others.
After all,
we only see Ozymandias through the eyes
of the sculptor and the sculptors work
through the eyes of the traveler and the
traveler is common through the words of
the poet.
I think this is so applicable to
breaking bad and to this episode
particularly because what makes drama
work,
what makes it interesting isn't
climactic action scenes or the bombastic
declaration of colorful characters or
even big ideas.
It's the succession of reactions that
cascade off of every choice,
that chemical and emotional reactions of
people living together on earth these
days.
There is an incredible pressure for show
runners have a show like this to have an
end in mind to stick the landing with
big payoffs and developments that will
shock all of us.
Well Ozymandias has those things,
but I give the writers and director
major credit for sticking to what
matters in an incredibly important
episode for letting us see Walter White,
king of kings undoing through the many
eyes of those who loved him.
There is a brand new nerd writer video
every week,
so if you click that box that I've set
up right there,
you'll subscribe to this channel and get
all those videos and I really appreciate
that.
I have to thank squarespace for
sponsoring this video and they've never
asked to interfere in the content which
is a standard of mine for sponsorships
and they're amazing for that.
If you don't know,
they make sleek intuitive websites.
I just made one called the nerd
writer.net.
You can check that out and if you sign
up for a year,
you can get a free domain name and for
use the offer code nerdwriter.
You can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
Thanks guys for that and I will see you
all next Wednesday.